Israel's designated prime minister
Benjamin Netanyahu has succeeded in
forming a new right-wing coalition
government he made the announcement
after weeks of negotiations with
religious and far-right political
Partners Netanyahu LED his party to win
the most seats in Israel's November
election but needed Coalition Partners
to govern Netanyahu who is Israel's
longest serving prime minister will head
the most right-wing Administration in
Israel's history
the Coalition agreement includes plans
for judicial and security reforms
critics fear the new alliance will sow
deeper divisions in the country
Benjamin Bibi Netanyahu May soon add a
new chapter to his Memoirs published
during the election campaign Israel's
former prime minister is back but this
time Netanyahu sealed his return with
the help of a controversial far-right
Alliance everything now is depends on
Netanyahu because Netanyahu
can be a reasonable prime minister even
if you do not vote for him or not like
him he can run Israel and he can run
conflict he can do it the question is
his Partners who are his partners and
that's the problem his Partners the
openly anti-arab and homophobic Ultra
nationalist religious Zionism Alliance
its leaders are better smoothridge
benga we are here during the election
campaign has been convicted for
incitement and barred for military
service because of his extremist views
death to Arabs no no no
whoever wants to live here in peace
but whoever is throwing molotovs whoever
is killing children killing women is a
terrorist
so what do we want
debt to terrorists
critics are concerned about their
ultra-nationalist religious agenda
becoming mainstream in Israeli politics
and their verbal attacks on Israel's
Arab minority among them elected members
of Israel's parliament the knesset for
getting me and attacking me
in order to attack the whole Arab and
Palestinian community
when he is saying death to terrorists
he says death to Arabs as he said before
10 or 5 or 3 years
we are talking about very extreme and
racist
Jewish politician
party became the third largest political
force in the November 1st election their
strong showing has split the country
even more
I feel frankly scared and also
disappointed around 400 000 people voted
for the new uh MPS Penfield and smutlich
and these two people have I find
appalling opinions
and that's personally also endanger me
as a woman as a leftist in this country
and also as a LGBT person
I think most people voted for Ben gevir
because of the security situation in
Israel we really want the security to
improve
I think people are longing for someone
who does act and not only talks
I personally know Ben Geer I was working
in his Law Firm when he was a lawyer I'm
also a lawyer
and I can tell you that he's true to his
word
netanyahu's new government is likely to
be one of the most right-wing in
Israel's history
well for more let's go to Jerusalem
where DW's Rebecca Ritter's is standing
by for us Rebecca this government is
considered to be the most right-wing
Israeli government ever what will this
mean for life in Israel
yeah that's right Anthony I mean this
isn't the first right-wing government of
course that Israel has ever seen but it
is being dubbed the most right wing with
Benjamin netanyahu's liquid party the
stall what a right-wing party now
sitting on the the Left Flank of this
Coalition and that of course is likely
to bring in some pretty big changes for
lives for the lives of Israelis and
Palestinians both here in Israel and in
the West Bank and when you look at the
uh talk about the big ticket items
you've got the occupation and the
situation with Palestinians you heard uh
some of it in that report there this
many of the new right-wing leaders of
the Coalition leaders uh in within this
new uh Coalition a pro-annexation uh
they've used very anti-arab rhetoric
racist rhetoric as you heard they're in
the report even towards uh knesset
members and we're likely to see more of
that now some of uh agreements have
already been made in the lead up in the
Coalition talks and and many more direct
Powers being given even now being
promised when it comes to security both
within Israel and the West Bank and of
course to the settlement policy now
we're likely to see potentially an
expansion of that settlement policy and
settlements that were considered
formally illegal under Israeli law even
we're likely to see them be legalized
that's already been promised to the new
Coalition partners and when you look
inside Israel itself you've got a very
controversial laws that have already but
they're already being talked about that
are already being promised to be changed
and this is a what's known as the
override law when it comes to the
Supreme Court giving the government more
rights to overrule the Supreme Court
giving them almost free reign on power
we're talking about a country that
doesn't have a constitution and it
doesn't have a second chamber of
government so the Supreme Court is
really one of the last checks on the
government that potentially being
scrapped as well we're looking at a
rollback of gay rights some of the the
Coalition Partners looking to even one
saying that the Jerusalem gay pride will
no longer be taking place they want to
look at reintroducing conversion therapy
things like that in a country that is
considered quite liberal when it comes
to gay rights you've got conservative
members of this Coalition now wanting to
roll back those rights also when it
comes to Jews immigrating here they're
wanting to to tighten those laws to in
adherence with strict Jewish law but you
know Netanyahu has accused critics that
they're fear-mongering that he is
actually in control that the Coalition
are joining him uh and that he's not
joining the Coalition and that no one
need to worry because he's still in
control but of course that remains to be
seen Anthony and so this is Israel's
fifth government in less than four years
briefly how much hope is there that this
one has any more staying power
well I mean how long is a piece of
string and it is really hard to predict
this uh government or this Coalition of
parties did win a pretty large majority
when it comes to recent Israeli politics
they got 64 seats they needed 61 to
govern so that is considered quite a big
majority here but whether or not
Benjamin Netanyahu will be able to keep
together the differing the differences
in his Coalition partners and try and
maintain uh also Unity within his own
liquid party we've had some liquid
ministers uh expressing their discontent
and you know they potentially could lead
the party so he's got a little bit of a
buffer there with the 64 seats but
whether or not he's going to be able to
hold everyone together certainly remains
to be seen
Rebecca Ritter's into Jerusalem thanks
so much